thanks for tuning in to another episode
of let the be talk this episode is
brought to you by Squarespace start
building your website today at
squarespace.com enter the offer code Let
There Be talk at checkout to get 10% off
Squarespace build it
beautiful you got to use Squarespace man
I mean here's the thing building
websites is always so ridiculously hard
and then you're paying someone to put it
together and then you want to update it
and you got to get a hold of that guy
and he's maybe he moved to like London
and now you can't have them update your
podcast or your website not your podcast
ah I'm out of it I'm on nightquil today
still got a sore throat head cold how
long's this thing last hopefully
Squarespace can get rid of my
cold but seriously Squarespace man it's
incredible you can build a website it
looks totally Pro there's no skill level
needed no coding required none of that
dumb nerd stuff it's easy to use also
you can get a free domain if you sign up
for a year on Squarespace start your
Squarespace free trial right now at
squarespace.com when you decide to sign
up for
Squarespace God this stuff is hard to
say when you when you decide to sign up
for square space make sure to use the
offer code Let There Be talk to get 10%
off your first purchase Squarespace
build it
beautiful I'm in the middle of building
a new website now I want to be
completely in control that's the only
way your website works is if you're
always updating it and keeping it fresh
make sure you use Squarespace and put in
Let There Be talk at the offer
code
[Music]
that's aand new
dance all right here it is it's um what
do we got Mar uh January 11th
I'm all spun out on
NyQuil throat is
crazy uh big big big show announced I'm
going to be 50 and I'm having a huge
party February 2nd if you live in Los
Angeles get your tickets right away cuz
this will sell out Del r at the lray a
night at the LR theater let me tell you
what we're doing we're going to do
comedy and rock and
roll so for the first half of the show
it's going to be Bill bur Joe Rogan
christalia Brian redband Joe bartnik and
myself doing
standup and then we'll Clear the Stage
do a little 10-minute uh intermission
and then come back with a full-blown
Allstar rockar tribute to Bon Scott
we're going to uh do some ACDC we're
going to play the Highway to Hell album
in its entirety with some incredible
cele Liberty rock and
rollers Chris Goss will be there for
Masters of Reality Rudy Saro on base we
got Bill burs gonna play some
drums uh Josh Z who was in an incredible
band called protein back in the day who
is Angus Young uh Billy Row from Jet Boy
on rhythm
guitar uh Ronnie Crawford on drums he's
played with everyone including myself in
my
band and then uh Dave Lombardo from
Slayer and a bunch of other uh secret
Jammers don't miss it lray Theater
February 2nd 8:00 p.m. get your tickets
right away for this it will sell out
lray Theater Los
Angeles all
right uh episode's late today because uh
I went to go see tul last night with
Rory
Scoville and my boy Greg at Al cahon
elone Harley we spun down to
uh San Diego to see tulle and
Primus I'm still got sore throat but I
couldn't miss
it and I got to tell you man
wow I can't [__] believe and I went
last year and I said this and I'm saying
it again I can't [__] believe how
insane tulle
is I
mean here's a band I've been seeing
since the '90s and they're [__]
selling out Arena still no new record
disappeared for
years and just come out and [__]
destroy just pure art man and and I got
to tell you Primus just blew my [__]
mind I had seen Primus since back on the
anthrax I think it was Anthrax Public
eny Primus
tour I mean that's how long ago I saw
Primus and they came out Les Claypool
just destroying
man and it's funny because I never
realized it back in the day
but it it's it was really obvious to me
last night how much dvo influenced
Primus it was really uh really apparent
and really cool I was like Wow and
Primus [__] man I'll go see them again
uh when they headline I am in on that
man they just an all around amazing
evening went down early got some Ramen
hit a record store picked up the black
crows three snakes in a
charm on
vinyl and and uh got a couple great dead
records on
vinyl anyway an incredible evening comes
to a smashing halt as we step outside
and get the news that David Bowie had
passed this is just [__] mindboggling
to
me you know he just drops a new record
I'm excited I'm thinking oh he's going
to go on tour again I'm going to get to
see him
no idea no idea that he's sick 18 months
cancer kept it on the
low and it just [__] floored me as I
rode home in the car we listened to
Bowie all the way home
and and I just think back the first time
I saw Bowie I loved Bowie growing up the
first time I saw Bowie was in
Petaluma at the I think it was
the I think I think it was the Showcase
Theater I went to go see man that fell
to Earth that movie I was
young maybe fifth or sixth
grade and I remember watching the whole
thing like what that thing
sucked I didn't understand it at all you
know I was young I was like what is
that but I realized a few years later
that that film was amazing and actually
got me to love like art
films you know like something didn't
need to make sense or or or be hit over
the head with what it was
about and it really set me on a course
of uh cool movies my entire
life and then I see Bowie live in 1983
at the US Festival my mom loved Bowie I
loved
Bowie uh I saw him at the US Festival
absolutely destroy and then my mom and I
saw him at the
A's Oakland Coliseum where the A's play
Return of the Thin White Duke tour let's
dance China girl all
that and I [__] love that
record uh it it was incredible to see
him of course you know Stevie Ray played
on that
record
um Nile Rogers produced
it it was an amazing record of hits
totally different than of course his 70s
Ziggy and all that radical stuff but the
songs were amazing and that's what at
the end of the day a lot of times I
think people don't talk about Bowie's
songs yeah they talk about like
you know his like craziness and his uh
Arty looks and his different stage
personas but I think a lot of times they
never talk about the
songs and man does he have some [__]
songs Jean jeie Rebel Rebel suffer Jet
City uh Diamond Dogs Heroes The Man Who
Sold the World which was incredibly
covered by Nirvana on that unplugged
concert my favorite Fame uh Golden Years
Young
Americans uh you know China girl like I
said
before uh what else is he uh let's dance
I love Let's Dance Under Pressure come
on man
fashion [__] fashion is great Modern
Love scary monsters I mean come on man
this [__] guy has a city of hits and
incredible
songs then I saw him with the
uh
uh tin
machine which was
amazing and then I saw him once at The
Warfield and I still have the poster for
this where it was a weird night where he
de djed for an hour and then he played
for a couple hours and that was Radical
to see him in this small venue he hadn't
been around for a long time and he poof
pops up at The
Warfield I could go on and on about
Bowie you
know it's it's
unbelievable
unbelievable that he is gone 69 years
old I mean how the [__] is cancer still
around it just blows my
mind you know and I think I'm I'm
getting to that age where my heroes are
are going to start dying and it's uh
it's really going to be over man which
made me think last night as I saw tul
and Primus and I've seen some great
great bands in the last
year these bands you know they'll carry
on they'll they'll carry the
torch I mean Maynard you know he's got
some Bowie in him you know he has Bowie
in him back to the perfect circle with
the wigs and you know even last night he
was dressed like kind of like a cop in
the Dark full art art
performance of course of course Maynard
has Bowie in him
everyone has Bowie in
them anyone that's a Glam rocker or an
art rocker Marilyn
Manson he's got boow in him hell
yes it's just crazy he's
gone I just can't believe
it you
know Scott
Wyland yeah we lost him he
worshiped Bowie he worshiped
Bowie I remember my man uh Jacob Dylan
doing an amazing cover for for the I
think it was the Godzilla
movie wallf Flowers did Heroes loved it
when we were out on the road they played
it every night just
rocking
man gonna miss you David Bowie big
time
anyway it's
crazy rough day rough day in
music I want to read a couple great
emails I got and then we'll get to the
episode which by the way the episode is
[__] fire today it's Bill Burr and
Dave Lombardo and we talk drums and
comedy and
life and I love this episode we recorded
it live last week at the all things
comedy
studio and uh I love both these men and
I just so happy that uh I know him you
know I'm going to read this first email
here it's from Luca and uh I'm gonna
[__] his last name up matosic Luca
matosic Hey Dean it's Luke I live in
Croatia that's right I just said
Croatia that's where this email is
coming from and these emails blow me
away and are the reason I love doing
this [__]
podcast I don't have Twitter or Facebook
so I wanted to thank you via
email I went through a c a rough year
had cancer and did six months of chemo
12 cycles and you and a couple other
podcasters made my my life better all
those hours in the hospital or at home
sick after therapy podcast saved my life
and made me go through the day if you
ever come to Croatia don't be a stranger
and keep up the good
work amazing amazing that [__]
email that is that that just makes this
podcast 100% worth it
I love you brother and uh stay strong
and keep rocking you
know I'll read you one more and I'm just
reading these because they were uh
pretty
touching let's see
here this one comes from Ron
Burns I wanted to thank you for all the
amazing guests you have introduced me to
on your podcast as well as shot jackets
I've never considered wearing a leather
jacket until I heard you talk about them
so thank you so
much um you are real inspiration and
having heard you on Joe Rogan Experience
you've gone to the front of my line and
podcast ever since thanks for all you do
stay
rad another amazing
email those make those just make the
[__]
day thank you for the
emails keep subscribing
people and uh play some Bowie
today leave a review on the podcast it
helps man I'm trying to get to 600 what
am I at right now let me look I'm at
uh if you leave reviews it it puts the
podcast up in the top 50 that's how this
wackiness
works I don't know how that is but
uh
let's see what I'm
at I'm at
463 trying to get to 500 man it's easy
people just leave reviews it takes like
one second like someone left one
yesterday it was
uh Dean gets it done rock and roll till
we die boom that quick Adam beefy cheesy
whiskey all right I got to go I want to
get you guys on this episode real quick
before you start it up if you want to
donate to the podcast hit
patreon.com Delray super easy leave
whatever you want it helps to
podcast and uh
patreon.com Dean Delray and get those
tickets to the lray Delray at the lray
light the candles happy Monday keep it
going Bowie love you hey what's
happening we got another episode of let
be talk here this is let be drum talk
today we have Bill Burr and Dave
Lombardo bill and I did one about two
years ago with Brian tishy where we just
talked that was not two years ago it
wasn't what do you think Oh I thought
you definitely knew that felt like may
please say it was a year and a half man
by two that was like 10 years
ago I think it was two years ago man I
don't know but uh it it was it was very
popular show we talked bonso and then of
course uh Dave Bardo being one of my
favorite drummers ever uh the king of
the double Bas pedal uh first time I saw
you Slayer just blew my mind like what
that's got to be fake you know
like like wow and and you're not even
sweating when you
play yeah it's just you're used to
you're conditioned and you know you
build up your stamina you it's like a
runner you know if if you take on you
know a you know a marathon you're not
going to be able to do five miles you
know off the B you have to build right
and it's exactly I never had the
discipline to learn how to I got B I
finally bought the I became obsessed
with botom and I was like until you play
Good Times bad times with one pedal I'm
not going to mess with and then I never
got to the good time bad times thing and
I never did the double pedal one time I
I tried playing out with one and uh we
did a panta song and I I sort of but it
was sort of uh was that Cowboys from
Hell so it wasn't too too fast but I
still [__] the whole thing up
especially towards the end of the song
but I think you guys like you got all
the double Bas drum uh players man are
[__] amazing
amazing to me I think it's the coolest
sounding drums especially back in the
day you know like when you got into the
early Slayer it was so [__] fast and
you would just hear this double Bas and
it would be perfect man it sounded like
a Harley you know there was no click we
did not follow a metronome you know
during those sessions and we recorded on
the tape so it wasn't like like today
what you know we have computers fixing
all the oh little drum parts and
everything everything is you know well I
just love that there was nobody as fast
as your band so you had to learn like
anybody can like like I find like on
YouTube like well there was no YouTube
back there then but you can if someone
can always break down what somebody did
but I'm always amazed like the first guy
but everyone was just like oh my God L's
Metallica this is the fastest feet ever
and then you guys came was it 86 uh with
rain and blood yeah I was just like oh
my a whole other level yeah so you might
what were you thinking when you guys
were playing at that Tempo you must have
been the fastest guy around out there
not to just I know there was music going
on but still just the blinding speed was
ridiculous yeah I feel we were the
fastest nobody else you know could
compare to us uh at that time and if
anybody tried it was like H it's not
there you know so how did you develop a
technique to go faster than anybody had
um you you start off slow you know the
songs start off at a at a at a pace
where or at a Tempo that that you could
work at right and then as you learn the
song and and get it and and everybody's
you know and you perform live uh you
know your adrenaline kicks in so the
song becomes faster and then it faster
because they had no limitations you know
we could just play You're basically
saying just sit down for a th hours and
you get it I always want the shortcut is
there like a technique a slide thing
that can be doing no you got to sit
people always ask me how'd you get in at
that place uh dude the work uh they walk
on they don't want to hear that the
thing I love about your plane is it's
it's not necessarily how fast it is it's
super fast but grooves cuz any a lot of
guys can play like but there's no Groove
you guys had this insane Groove going
you know well I listened to Zeppelin
yeah and bonam which we've talked about
before it's one of my favorite drummers
and you know you listen to those songs
there's so much swing and so much Groove
you know I picked up on it and also the
music I used to listen to when I was a
kid um you know I listen to a lot of
Latin jazz and and percussive like music
from from Cuba you're Cuban right yeah I
was born I came to the states when I was
two um you know you just pick up on this
groove and this Rhythm and I kind of
applied it to to rock and roll because I
was fascinating with rock music you know
here in America my parents would listen
to Cuban music but then when I was on my
own or in my bedroom i' listen to Kos
and kme and who who was the bands were
you listening to punk or or Rock uh
growing up when I was like 15 16 uh I'd
listen to of course Zeppelin Jimmy
Hendrick
Foreigner um I was into har
um whatever was on the radio at that
time you know and was classic rock you
know the hard stuff this was what I like
the most there was one time on the radio
station I heard the wanton song by
Zeppelin which was a song I never heard
before and I was like wow that's heavy
and I remember going through my friend's
albums and and trying to find that song
it's like I'm looking for a song by
Zeppelin and I don't know what album
it's off of and I was just searching you
know frantically searching for the song
cuz I felt it was amazing it was hard it
was powerful yeah all those all that
kind of music you know the kind of music
that was more powerful and and driven
were the songs that I liked that I would
always search for I would never like the
like I I enjoyed the Rain song but it's
not something I was like passionate
about you know that sounds cool I think
all drummers that can Grove somehow
always had some sort of jazz background
and that's why I think so many of those
kinds of players like coming out of the
50s and 60s cuz the music before it was
big ban into Bop and all of them at
least listen to their parents record so
they had that that swing pulse in them
so then when they applied it to rock
It's still grooved and then I think like
my generation came along and ours was
the misinterpretation of bonum where
just like you just [__] swing from
behind your ears and like that's how you
get like this big sound and we and it
just became this really like I don't
know if you watch you know people always
get [__] for having no rhythm if you
watch white people if you listen to Live
records like somewhere in the 60s we
lost it like in Big B swing it was
impossible not to like clap on two and
four it was just so heavy that you knew
where it was but somewhere around there
it became the Clapping on all four beats
and then it went to clapping on one and
three but if you look at [__] from like
the 1950s where it's 1 2 3:00 they
clapping on the beat or you watch I
watched something uh with the the Dave
Breck band and I look at all white
people they're all on time they this is
amazing and then somewhere somewhere
around it all just became where's that
at yeah yeah it all just kind of came it
just became like this falling down the
stairs kind of thing so um I've always
there and that was something that like
one of the hardest things that I had
with like speed Mel and everything was
it was so fast that if the if there
wasn't a Groove I just couldn't get into
it and my brothers got really into that
a lot of that type of stuff and I I sort
of stayed back and I liked Metallica uh
I'm so bad with the names of the song
the song no what what's the what's the
their their classic
that oh yeah yeah um yeah master puppets
yes yes so the the [__] when they go
into the verse the [__] guitar rhythm
in that is so [__] sick it gives me
chills every time except they chop off
that 1/8 note that always destroys me
it's like why don't you just [__]
keep it going man that was killer um
play with uh Metallica oh I know yeah I
remember seeing that on the I miss
everything I found out about that like a
year after you did I what the [__] I
would have loved to have seen that but
um but like I always like was in the
bands like if they didn't have that um
that I I just it just couldn't it was
just this wall it was amazing what they
were doing but if if there wasn't that
Groove there if there wasn't anything
that gave me the chills I could never
get into that but when I finally sat
down cuz the first time I I I was going
to like from like hair metal to you guys
so it was you guys were like light years
beyond what I was listening to so I I
had to come back to you guys like 10
years after that came out and I was just
like oh my God this is [__]
unbelievable so I was way behind on all
of that stuff I I think I think really
the um the spotlight on double base was
probably the one video by Metallica
remember when they go into that mine has
taken my sight they really closed up on
his feet they show yeah they showed you
the that was the Ringo on the uh Ed
Sullivan Show for double bass players
and they finally showed it like he like
he's [__] doing that that's unreal
that's what that was man right
like just as far as that the amount of
double based players that that probably
like inspired you know I know people
give Lars a lot of [__] and the guy he
basically I don't understand why he gets
so much [__] that guy [__] like there
was no road map to that style of music
true I agree with you for yeah and and
all the stuff that you were doing like
no one's gone faster than your band and
now you're the drummer in the band you
got to figure out how to do it like I
thought it took a long time for you guys
genre music to get respect even from
like a guy like me forget about critics
like I was just kind of like it's too
fast they're yelling I don't understand
what's going on and then I was listening
to like Britney Fox girl school
like no no I got a girl SCH oh I got
some uh they were the third they were
the third AOL Smith so you had AOL Smith
then you had Cinderella then you had
Britney it just it just kept getting it
kept getting more and more water it was
like drugs that were stepped on
only was left was just a mic stand with
handkerchiefs hanging off of it would be
like the fourth one but yeah I listened
to uh you know they weren't all bad but
I listen to some I listened to I let a
lot of great shows like I could I was
old enough I could have saw you guys in
your first tour and I didn't yeah yeah
bad move yeah and those bands just
created more anger within Slayer it's we
wanted to get yeah CU they were an LA
band and they were like around while all
the Glam was hitting on on Sunset Strip
and where were you guys playing you know
uh we were playing in Orange County
where was that where the metal scene was
uh not really metal more of a the punk
scene right like Circle Jerks and stuff
like that yeah Di adolesence and uh so
we were playing the the clubs there I
mean I think we played gazari one time
one time yeah and we never returned we
would never step foot at the rainbow
because it was how was the reaction when
you played uh Garis uh I think there was
probably three or four other bands
playing that night I I honestly don't
remember but I remember we got out of
there pretty quick some of the bands
that were there you know we were playing
covers but we were playing Iron Maiden
oh you playing covers at that time very
we played the the
Troubador um yeah those are the only two
clubs in La we played at what point did
you realize that that sunsets like that
scene was not going to be right for you
guys was it just the lack of gigs or was
it something that you guys our style in
general I mean we we weren't into
dressing
like you know we weren't into
that the furthest we went was uh adding
eyeliner yeah you know which is on the
first album you know pictures of us
wearing eyeliner and but that's also
could go evil you know yeah exactly and
we took that from from Aussie yeah you
know and uh we felt that we did not
belong in that genre at all and um so we
went heavier we went Punk we went uh you
know aggressive instead of puckering our
lips you know we flipped people off you
know threw beer cans and you know raised
hell Bill Bill was recently we were
talking about um the drummer for Rush
and he's retiring because he has carpal
tunnel and Bill said he saw it one point
he went back to traditional grip and I I
remember when I had you on the podcast
before you really talked about your body
does not swing like a Tommy Lee [__]
he guy you're really right here you know
you're like right here so your body said
your sockets don't get worn out and
stuff you know yeah I mean I've I think
I've mastered the ergonomics of of My
Drum Set where I don't have to reach far
for anything and uh for any of the
symbols or any of the toms and I think
that's saved you know my joints and now
I'm still you know painfree really yeah
still that's incred I'm really happy
about real fortunate because I hear a
lot of you know stories from drummers
that are you know having carpal syndrome
and needing uh surgery and you know I I
couldn't even you know imagine the pain
that those guys go through um you know
every now and then I do have maybe
muscle muscle aches but that's normal
you know if you haven't played for a
while you know so yeah seen some drummer
in like a really pop band just he just
couldn't do it anymore like his
shoulders were worn out it was and it
was like this guy played Arenas and he
was playing to the back of the house and
he was I don't know what he was doing
but like I heard he just wore out his
shoulders and it was just like bone on
bone and I was just like playing that
yeah so you know I would look at that
and then look at his drum set and say
okay that symbols you know too high or
or you know this crash or this China you
need to bring these Toms down you know I
would look at it from a different
perspective and some some of these guys
they just don't they don't know you
remember the early 80s when the cool
thing was to have your ride symbol like
three stories up and you just be
reaching up I remember Steve Jordan had
his when he used to play in Letterman he
had his up there Omar had his way up
there and I was just like I remember
like trying to like raise up the thing
and I would literally be like playing a
song and all the blood is like going
down in your shoulder it's like my arm's
falling asleep it's like the AP hangers
of uh of symbols you know yes I've never
understood how you can ride a motorcycle
like that Dean with with the the the
what do you call them ape arms AP
hangers yeah it's incredible because
it's way more comfortable really it's
really weird because your arms rest on
it and there's a weird flow to it down
here when you're riding and your bars
are down here you start to get neck
pinch where this is like your arms and
and everything's looking straight and
and then it's a night and what about the
blood the blood's not like no it doesn't
do any it's it's it's crazy like it's it
seems like the old once I rode like that
I was like I'm never going back but like
the neck pinch was gone you know your
shit's down here also when you're here
you can really fly between the cars you
can see good wow you know you can you
can kind of see them all right I can see
what's going on here they're like you
back to riding right this Maniac did you
see him during that time when he got his
whole side of him looked dude he looked
like he went through a cheese grater his
whole side like up and down up and down
[__] some lady hit me man doing 70 on
the on the 110 freeway no just insane
Bill saved me came over and brought me a
pie some T-shirts are like quadruple x
t-shirts so it wouldn't touch his inti
like dude yeah he like high sighted the
bike and just like we probably going
like what how fast are you going like I
was doing about 55 or so because I was
just getting ready to go in the tunnel
so I slowed down cuz my my eyes changed
slow in you know tunnels so I just kind
of slowed down there was no one on the
road and so she I was doing like 55 so
she was easily doing 70 because it the
the amount of speed that she hit me I
was just riding I went what is that I
was
down yeah you know you know what weird
there is like so then he got a car and
he's just like 35 years of ride man you
know I'm lucky I walked away blah blah
blah blah blah hobbling around dude like
someone who got thrown off a bike doing
55 and then like 6 weeks later you're
like nah I'm riding again you did get a
car though I did get a car yeah and I
and uh like I just drove the car to the
Bay Area and you know I got the
satellite radio on and I'm just driving
up to the punch line and all the metal
surrounding you yeah yeah yeah aags I
had heated seats it was really cold it
was like 31 degrees I heated seat all
right and I was just in my own world
like this is great you know yeah then
you don't notice people on motorcycles
that's what happens join this side the
last time I ever rode I rode with him
and we I always wanted to ride all the
way down to Sunset to the ocean and come
back and I was [__] riding on the way
out there and I was going around like a
a turn that went to the left and
somebody on the other side was coming
around and they were went a little over
the double line and like my head was
lined up with the side of their [__]
car and I had to come up and then go
back into it so I didn't come out of
turn dude I got off the bike when we
went to uh get gas when I shut it off I
was shaking and I thought was the
vibration of the bike and when I was
sitting down and I was trying to drink
my Coke and I'm still doing that I was
like all right this is this is he looked
at me goes I'm done he I was glad he was
done because everybody kept saying man
you're GNA Kill Bill Burr man that's not
cool man tell him not to ride dude he's
he's big he's blown up in his career and
you're like I'm the guy out there with
the drugs get on this heroin you know
what I mean I'm like it ain't me man it
ain't me I don't want him to ride that
shit's scary I had an accident back in
2004 I was dirt bikes yeah oh wow I was
really into dirt bikes and Motocross I
was going to all the shows everything
and I bought my kids I had two boys and
I bought him a little 80 and a little U
100 and I had a 250 and we went to the
to Dumont Dunes you know where that's at
off the 15 going up to Vegas and uh I
was riding having a great time you know
they gave me some warnings you know be
careful there's these Razorback uh sand
dunes you know they they're gradual CL
but then it cuts off at the end oh [__]
yeah yep and was it uh about 65 ft 70 ft
and uh I
miscalculated and they told me to go
along the edge and look down to see if
you can drop down well I miscalculated
and the edge came too soon and next you
know I'm mid air and I see all the you
know the RVs and the campers are about
this small and I'm like
oh [__] here I go bam and then I hit I
hit the sand and uh crushed the side of
my skull down to the right and oh with
the helmet with the helmet I had all the
gear all the gear you wor about your
spine coming down like that with no ramp
or anything yeah nothing and you know
the sand you know you'll fall in but
then it just it just you know yeah rock
hard underneath it just rock hard and
what caused uh the damage on on my skull
was were the goggles oh wow so I hit the
crossbar I didn't you know brace myself
I hit the crossbar and crush the side of
my face I was so I was like oh I need to
blow my nose and something didn't feel
right cuz my jaw didn't
close I was like oh [__] I need to blow
my nose I you know blew my nose in my my
uh nasal cavity it was
cracked no and he just blew up it's a
poof they go Dave you need to down we
need to call the paramedics I like I'm
okay I'm okay they wanted to airlift me
but there was no spinal injury there was
nothing I was able to walk away oh God
was that it for you that was well no I
got back on the bike a week
later yeah I think that's the difference
that's the difference between lifetime
Rider and some else I had one of those
close calls and that was it I do uh I do
miss it but like if I was ever going to
do it like uh I would want to be in the
middle of nowhere yeah and uh you know
like Wyoming on a long road no one
around yeah yeah I never went back to to
Bill and I went dirt bik rided dirt bike
is great trail that was fun I fell down
when I was doing that but you I fell in
the dirt I was going like you know half
a mile an hour I had all this [__] on
that was fine but just I could never get
past just riding down the road and
there'd be a car next to me and you just
think if they don't see me right now and
they just they just come over here I'm
going to be underneath that car God
willing I'll die instantly instead of
getting dragged down the
stop stop stop stop I'm I'm on your
bumper yeah oh I tell you I still hear
the sound that's the thing that trips me
out I still hear the sound cuz it was so
weird but I remember I told Bill as I
was sliding down the highway I just
thought well I got no regrets you know I
had no regrets it like [__] amazing
life I got back on the bike after a
while you know uh but I've since I I've
sold them and I haven't ridden so yeah
yeah um were you playing in slayer at
the time yeah and you went out with like
a busted up cheat or were you guys off
actually I had uh some shows with
phantomas and my P yeah and I went on
stage and you know I had the stitches
and everything was all screwed up and um
he said dude you need a pirates
patch I said yeah that fits in fit in
perfect mik Patton just dude get a
pirate patch you know an eye patch I
said hey what's the worst thing that
happened like technically on your drum
kit like during a big gig like big gig
you're going to be on TV and like a bass
drum head breaks or something well it's
similar um my first hit it's a
uh count four one two three
four crack that my my beater on the bass
drum just snaps and I have to go into a
double Bas section you know immediately
so I just sat there and I couldn't play
so my tech came up and pulled the pedal
out put another one in and I resumed and
the band still just playing the song
yeah you just keep going yeah this was a
a live Festival it was people were there
H festivals uh probably 30 50 30 50,000
people for all they know I mean it was
probably a you know a microphone that
went out or something yeah you know we
didn't you know make a big deal out of
it I just kept on how the [__] does that
guy change it and then tune it up so it
sounds good you don't have any time to
do sound beer it was the beater that
snapped the actual beater broke oh Jesus
Christ it was the beater so we were able
to replace it was either the pedal the
entire pedal or or or just the beater I
think it was the entire pedal with a
drum head I don't know we tried to make
sure you know we change our drum heads
you know frequently so it doesn't it
doesn't happen at what level do you have
to get where they have all the extra
[__] like at the gig like earli in your
career if you broke that thing you were
[__] you had to grab the other bass
drum pedal and just be like all right
playing single base the rest of wow did
that ever happen like your [__] break
down like the double Bas pedal the chain
I never used a double Bas pedal I always
used a double bass Right double bass
drum um I mean I there were times where
I think I had a you know I had to have
had an extra pedal and I just put it on
myself yeah you know there's been times
where I've broken snare drums and you
keep playing you know you just keep
hitting him until you know you have time
to change it that's when you're working
by yourself but if you have somebody
helping you out they immediately change
it for you that's my favorite scene and
Let There be Rock the movie they're
playing and his snare drum breaks and
and he's just keeping time on the high
hat and you see the guy change it and
he's smoking a cigarette at the same
time and just un that gu nothing rattles
him nothing and then it's on and he's
like you know I mean that's a you said
you like Phil red a lot right yeah I do
I do that guy has has a a really good
swing and and and uh style um whereas
there was one guy that took his place
for a while I think Simon right no not
Simon oh the bald guy yeah yeah he's in
it now what's his name chis yeah Chris
Slade from The Firm yeah yeah I don't I
didn't you know my apologies you know
War gets out to him I'm just not a fan
right um you know but Phil Rudd yeah
he's amazing he has really good swing
and amazing time he's like the perfect
fit for that band yeah yeah yeah who
starts doing meth in your 60s it's just
[__] unbel I was so psyched when he
came back because that was that was my
band and uh by the time I I got into him
I saw the Simon
Wright uh Angus Malcolm cliff and uh
Brian version of it and then I saw uh
when when he finally came back I don't
know 13 years later whatever it wasn't
until the Black Ice tour that I finally
saw him I got to be like I'm finally
getting to see him you know he had the
cigarette going the [__] glasses and
stuff he was so cool and
um yeah to see him get booted again like
I was so there was two big like guys
getting kicked out of bands drummers
that [__] crushed me when I was
coming up and it was it was Phil Rudd
the first time after the flick of the
switch recording when he got bounced and
Steven Adler oh yeah when he got kicked
out of guns and Rose I was oh man cuz
that guy came along I've talked about
this a million times I just love there
was so many guys in those hair metal
bands that would have like these giant
double Bas kits and they were just
playing 44 and they they would just have
the double Bas for the solo for the
logos or some of them didn't even have a
pedal behind the other one it was just
the look good yeah and then so and you
could have like the band you know if
your band was the whatever you know or
you could even just it just one word you
could have it on both sides and they'd
have two rack two floor toms the double
China a Gong behind him and all they
were playing was this two4 [__] and then
uh he came along and he had a little
four piece kit with the ride you know
where that second Tom would be the
second rack Tom would be it was just the
coolest setup and I just he was using
all of it you know uh like an appe was
it a Welcome to the Jungle got the floor
tom pattern he's got the cowbell thing
before will farell and that sketch
killed cowbell forever but that part
where it's
like I mean that's a hard [__] part
to play people don't realize it but you
put 10 drummers on there and it's not
going to feel the same Adler not all
it's it's just really musical too I just
thought he was really musical like where
he hit crash symbols when when he didn't
and he just like you could just tell
this guy's really thinking this through
and then also he has the gift and I just
thought the way he played he had this
weird thing where was laidback but he
was like on the front of the beat it
like a punk kind of thing but also
laid-back I loved his [__] playing
and when he got kicked out I was I was
devastated I was you know I was a young
kid so I was like you know [__] the bed
it's not the same bed anymore um but of
course when use your Illusions came out
you know I was all over it but uh I was
I was devastated when that happened so
what what drummer is going to be coming
back for we don't know yet that's what's
crazy it's like um here's what here's
what I site they're finally going to do
I was I was I was thinking like man they
got like like it was one of those like
things like if they don't do that in the
next couple years that's never going to
happen yeah yeah because you know Axel
can only was probably sing that for so
much longer you know what I mean I
thought his voice was still pretty good
it was great I'm just saying if you
waited five more years like I saw him
last year it's funny because Twitter
lights up you know and they're like ah
[__] them no Izzy no ader know me and
all this dumb [__] yeah nobody cares
yeah it's like what are you talking I'll
take you a ticket yeah what yeah what
are you talking about but I saw and then
they said oh Axel sounds terrible now
none of these people I don't even think
go to the shows or anything I saw him at
the plaum last year played like four
nights he [__] sounded great and I
remember exactly I was telling Burr this
that he said look I can sing everything
exactly the same but Rocka Queen is hard
as [__] and when you think about it that
is so high when it starts at it's like I
got everything imaginable right before
my eyes it's so high you know well maybe
you should sing it after after I hit him
up on Twitter I said hey man I'll be
that guy up there in the right corner
you know
yeah but uh I mean you know I he was
supposed to be on Kimmel tonight
and then he cancelled now I don't know
what the inside on me
says he probably didn't get these
contracts signed with the other members
yet you know there's some contracts sign
this this is what you're making like say
the other guys and maybe they didn't get
him signed yet and he's like well I
can't go on and announce the lineup yet
the weekend the lawyers say wait what's
this or whatever I don't know that's
what I think probably yeah but you know
so far it's just just hope it happens
yeah it's yeah yeah right exactly it's
Duff slashing Axel so far and let's hope
that Axel you know makes it to the stage
well you know in the last three years he
stopped going late and everything PE and
they warned you they emailed you like
hey he doesn't go on late anymore he
used to get an email from TIG Master
he's on right at time maybe 10 minutes
off I the plum that [__] was on spot
on four minutes late I was like yeah and
people were ready you know like oh he's
going to be on on time you know well I
always heard you if you go over all
those Union charges you'll actually
you'll you'll come off tour and owe
money if you're not if you're not
careful now if I remember correctly one
of their books Slash's book or something
he was talking about that or maybe
Adler's book I can't remember one of
their books um was saying that they
ended up having to after they finished a
big tour they had to go back out on
another tour because they didn't make
any money because of the giant
production and you know going on late
and all the overages and all of that
type of [__] it's triple time like you
just did the garden and uh you know you
go over it's triple time immediately for
those green coats you know and the
[__] that's insane man bird did the
garden I didn't realize that's triple
time triple time it's not even double
it's like trip why is it triple all the
sudden I asked them I said what time do
I have to be off by they were like 10:30
so I went to 10:28 like I almost did an
hour and a half like I wasn't going to
get off cuz it's like he said it was the
show of your life right it was it went
perfectly as far was just uh being such
a big thing and and I went on and I was
on I started riffing and it just never
sometimes sometimes you come out and
it's you're killing it and then you
almost can't follow what you did and
then then you get psychologically [__]
up by that and it kind of kills the rest
of the show but this was just one of
those nights everything went uh wow went
great and um you know what was cool is
we set up during the day um you know
paid for the place the whole day was I I
rented a drum kit and some amping me my
friends came down in an empty Madison
Square Garden just played all these
[__] songs oh yeah awesome but what
was cool is it kind of got over the
nervousness of of being there and the
whole uh you know I'm not worthy and all
that just to go in there and make a
bunch of noise and make an ass of myself
treat like a [__] playground yeah
Clubhouse then it just it when I came
out it almost felt like I was doing the
second show and it was just the first
show so um I did record just the audio
that night cuz uh I just think standup
specials look stupid there yeah when you
those Arenas it's like there's a
comedian and like a 200 foot curtain
behind him it just he always seems
really small and like I just think
comedy's more more of an intimate thing
and uh but I did want to document it so
I think I'm going to do another vinyl
thing and I'm put out all 90 minutes the
double vinyl that opens up like in the
old days I'm going to lose a ton of
money yeah it's going to be for like
total nerds yeah I love that double Song
Remains the Same now that was that was
one of the reasons you wanted to jam in
there what did you called you called the
special something right right yeah uh uh
does anybody remember laughter yeah
which is the the Robert PL thing that he
said and it kind of worked on two levels
where it was uh a nod to him and then
also with you know all the political
correctness of like you know all just
you know the over exaggeration of how
many people get offended which is what
it totally is I mean you do show after
show after show and nobody gives a [__]
and then one person raises his stink and
then they put him on TV like they
represented the CR like I I they [__]
stood half of them stood up that night
this is just one [__] right so yeah
it kind the whole thing uh worked out we
were going to do like a for the post to
put my head over a plant thing but I was
just like I'll probably get sued it's
too it's already too to on the nose so
um yeah but it was definitely uh
definitely definitely good time so that
had to be the highlight right I mean you
ever played the garden yes three times
three times yeah once with Slayer and
two times with phantomas opening for tul
oh wow that was epic cuz of course bonam
you know he played on that stage I just
kept looking at the ceiling me too yeah
it's all wood you got the wood slats
yeah yeah cuz they redid they gave it a
facelift but they kept that like to me
the roof is like iconic and uh there's
that one shot and Song Remains the Same
where they they just cut to the crowd
it's just a sea of hair and people not
knowing how to grow long hair so it's
just it's it's as out as it is long but
you actually see like the the the roof
it's funny a lot of the theaters that
want to play always goes back to music
to like guys that I saw playing there
and uh and I've always looked them up
it's a great thing about the internet
like um where ACDC played uh for the um
Let There be Rock uh the thing they made
right before Bond died oh yeah Let There
be Rock that was I looked that place no
it was a place in Scotland oh wow and uh
oh no I think that's where they recorded
the live album that's right you're right
they were in Paris yeah uh uh the live
album if you want BL want blood was done
in this this theater in um
I want to say Glasgow or Edinburgh and I
found out that it was knocked down I was
so bummed out I was like oh man I I G to
play that place that [__] record is I
I think it's the best ACDC Rec to me
back in the day it was the live records
that really got you going it was the
Frampton it was the Cheap Trick live at
Ted nent we talked about double live
Gonzo and the ACDC If You Want Blood
dude even Bob Seager had a decent
[__] had a great one he recorded in
Boston Garden and uh Detroit Detroit
yeah man that all the live records were
great you know you guys you did a live
record right what what's one did you
guys do a live record we did one in
Lakeland Florida Lakeland Florida some
some arena there Clash of the Titans I
believe oh that was a great tour who was
on that allice and chains Alison chains
Anthrax Mega Death yeah yeah [__] I saw
the origal C Palace I think it was or
Oakland one of the two Palace yeah any
drummers nowadays that you're that
you're watching that uh um yeah you
watch guys on
YouTube I mean there's some amazing
drummers out there I actually I saw you
know there's miny symbols they were
featuring a drummer and right now I
don't remember his name but it came up
on my news feed this guy was soloing
over these tracks and he was just
amazing I could there's so many great
drummers out there you know I don't
think a lot of them get enough you know
media attention
um or they're just not in bands that are
doing anything um uh there's some
hardcore drummers I like uh Gabe Serbian
who is the singer of my new band now but
he has uh another band called uh
um head wound City and uh and he played
in a band called The Locust very short
songs the titles of the songs are longer
you know than the songs read read than
the actual uh songs and uh he's really
fast HP he's got great technique um well
that's the thing now don't you think
with kids today it's like you could
literally as a kid you could go on
YouTube and in one night you could learn
or and watch like what it took me four
years of drum of going every Saturday
like they would just teach you here's a
parad and don't have your pinky sticking
out all right see you next Saturday I
mean I was a little more involved in
that but like you could sit there like
the first time I [__] up my foot was
trying to figure out how to how to do
those fast doubles and I had no idea how
to do it and I was doing something I was
like tring to do it with my just my big
toe at the top of the thing and I was
arching my thing and I got like planner
fish aritis and stuff I had no idea and
then it wasn't until like YouTube came
out it's like oh you just do like a
slide kind of thing it's like oh that's
all it is all right I'm I'm an idiot but
the kids now can see that as opposed to
having to slow a record down or you know
listen to it a thousand times with your
ear up to it and it just causes them to
like you know like there's kids out
there now just putting out you know drum
solo uh drum solos that they filmed and
they're like in their teens and it's at
the same level of guys when I first
started buying instructional dvds like
the late 80s likeo yeah it's like if
this guy could go back in town this in
time he could [__] put this out and
people would buy this and he's just some
kid in his parents house so um I I I I'm
Blown Away by what the younger kids are
playing now now bill I agree you play
you you played drums first before you
communion did you want to actually be in
a band you were in a band with your
brother or something what was going on
what happened was I was working in a w
my dad was like had music forced upon
him yeah he can play piano he can play
saxophone you just play by ear and um
but it was really forced on him so it
kind of killed the thing so I think with
him he didn't want it to force force it
on us so he had like a banjo and an
accordion had all this stuff laying
around the house and it wasn't until I
started working in a warehouse um I came
from real jock town and then there was
like a couple Towns over in Walpole
there was a lot of people that played
and these guys showed up and they were
all in a band I went out to see him and
I was like it's [__] cool and he
could play the songs in the radio I was
like he can learn how to do that so I
started with guitar and I got frustrated
really quickly and then I just switched
to drums because I had more of an
athletic upbringing and then the
physicality of it and then I just fell
in love with them and then I discovered
bonam and all these guys and um did you
play in any bands though I was more the
jam house like two my brothers play
guitar so and you weren't going to I
mean I had you know I was going to Lug
my drums around didn't have cases or
anything like that so it was just when
my parents went around kids would just
come over and um all these songs that
I'm playing now all the all the [__]
guns and& Ros of stuff all the ACDC
stuff uh a little bit of Metallica we
always had to be because I couldn't play
double base I had to figure out a way to
like uh and I couldn't afford a pedal um
you know I had to fake playing it but uh
yes but I think at one point I I sort of
I I just I I understood that I didn't
have the gift I understood that the best
like if I really dedicated myself I
could be a really solid drummer and a
really good cover band right like I can
ape what somebody already did yeah right
but you're not coming up [__] yeah to be
the guy that like came up with it which
is why Dave I hold you the way at the
level that I do because there was no
road map where all of a sudden it's like
all right now we're going to be faster
than anything else out there and it's
still got a Groove all right now you got
to figure out how to do it and I was one
of those people that yeah if you after
you did it and then an instructor broke
it down than I could like figure out how
to do it like I just you know I I still
to this day you know wish I was I wish I
had more of a gift and but I think it
worked out but uh there is those times
when I go into Guitar Center and I'll
just see some eight-year-old who just
has it yeah and he's already his
phrasing is already I'm just like oh
this kid's good he's goingon to be
better than me by October this is
[__] brutal um but it's it's
definitely like it's a it's a hobby uh
that I I definitely it's just it's
[__] awesome yeah you're [__] good
man I mean you know like we uh for a
comedian I'm not bad well you got you
got that's not really say anything stand
up comic I'm not P I think what people
don't understand about drums is meter
it's timing and uh you got it of course
from being a comedian and stuff but no
people that's a myth that they go do you
think yeah because you played drums that
affected your comedic timing it's like
too completely same principle but
totally I understand playing music into
the comedy world I know not the stomp on
the drums which is kind of like don't go
into the verse too soon or or the
precourse or whatever that's what I'm
talking about ping but like pacing yeah
but someone could pay play in a band for
[__] 50 years if they're not funny
they're not funny oh of course not of
course not and I've seen plenty of
interviews of unbelievable musicians in
the interview they're just kind like
well you know I kind of just was an idea
had and I was you know it's just like no
personality no nothing not even remotely
funny so I I think it's and then I've
seen like musicians out there who are
[__] hilarious oh yeah Jacob Dyan who
the funniest guy I know yeah and they
tell stories and stuff and it's just
like like this guy could like literally
be doing panel on a talk show right now
he's like that level funny so um I don't
know but I'm glad I basically just kept
playing drums when I moved to New York
then I couldn't play because you know I
lived in New York yeah and I stopped
playing for five years then I dated this
chick and she I I mentioned that I
played she always wanted to play so I
started teaching her and it got me back
into it so then for like the last 15
years I have been playing but um you
know I played for the first like it
wasn't until these like last couple
years I actually played out with other
guys and they finally dawned on me one
day going dude you've been sitting in
like a practice room for like 20 15
[__] years like isn't the point of
this to interact with other Humanity so
it's a really standup comic sort of
loner way that I kind of went into it
but uh you know um I'm kind of glad that
I did wait that long because it I you
know my talent was at the level it was
so it took me a long time just to get
decent and to understand just even what
the job of a drummer was which was
basically it doesn't make a difference
what you're playing if the people in the
crowd are just standing there thinking
about their
taxes you're not you're not doing the
[__] job and then that's when I
learned that by watching Steve Jordan
and being like because he would play
really simple stuff and it gave you the
chills and I'm like I can physically
play that but I can't make it sound
anywhere as good as that and that's what
I kind of dawned on me it's like dude
you've kind of learned everything 65%
and then moved on to the next and that's
why the whole thing sounds like a three4
bag of [__] so you got to go back and
start over again so I'm still in the
process of doing that but um what age
did you start
Dave in the
womb it's
um I I was around music uh you know
growing up my parents used to go to
parties and there'd always be bands
playing and Latin jazz bands you know
playing percussion so you know I was
always drawn to the drummers for some
reason and I I would sit there and I
just watch them and there were some
there was a time where we were at this
venue and it was like a family you know
dance party whatever it was I think it
might have been New Year's or something
and uh and I was sitting backstage and
my mom couldn't find me I was probably
10 years old or something she says there
you are I was sitting on the piano stool
watching the band from stage left she
said why don't you go outside why don't
you go you know go to the front dance
with some girls you know there's a lot
of kids running around I said no Mom I
want to stay right here I was just
watching the drummer and uh that that
was one one of the times and and there
were several other times that we were at
parties and and I was just fixated on on
what the drummer was doing and you know
how they would hit you know the passion
that they would play you know with and
um you know I I think that taught me a
lot you know just by watching these guys
at a young age and so then when I picked
up drumsticks I felt it kind of natural
you know to do what they were doing you
play lewig right uh now I'm back to Tama
oh Tama yeah you were on lewig for a
while yeah for a couple few years yeah
yeah does it matter to you what drums
you play I mean other than your sponsor
I'm saying Yeah well yeah don't get him
in
trouble we can be honest here yeah yeah
no because people go through phase there
was a years where DW was the king and
then I remember those the guy from Pearl
J was playing those aots with the wooden
[__] rims that guy in Canada and uh
you know everybody was like those were
the drums you know and I think uh you
know I mean for me Tama uh withstands my
hitting you know the way I hit it it uh
you know it tolerates it it doesn't fall
apart whereas you know maybe lwig you
know they have some great shells but the
hardware you know doesn't uh take the
abuse right you know Things Fall you
know you know the stance break somehow
you know and it's just I had a difficult
time when I was with that company but
you know I mean it's a great company a
great bunch of people you know great
drums uh but you know they need to work
on some other stuff and Tama for me just
is phenomenal it just really uh takes a
beating you ever go to that Pro Drum
Shop man that place the one on Vine or
yeah yeah what a [__] great store I
haven't been there I'd love to get there
you got to get in there dude these one
of the last times I went in there they
had Ed Shaun's whole drum kitten for
sale there and they still sounded great
he would get like two or three a year or
something like that and it it's he still
used to uh put his initials on his
symbols like they had the whole thing
wow there they had um just some of the
stuff I can't even like some of the old
kits you remember those kits that the
one with the tubes remember that well
they they did this thing where it almost
looked like the drums were like deflated
like you took air out of it like drums
in like the 30s or 40 they got one there
yeah an experimental Inc looks like it's
meled yes yeah like it melted they got
stuff like that somebody came in with
like a full set of like Vibes like Lial
Hampton like you could literally go out
with the count Bassy band level thing
over in the corner and like you know
they got a lot of [__] like that that
like you know people who aren't Pros go
in and just buy it for whatever [__]
reason but other than that that their
symbol selection and they it's a it's an
old school like music store where uh you
know sometimes they'll have to order
something but they always have like a
they got all kinds of just just all
kinds of bass drum pedals and all this
stuff all over the place it's it's
insane it's incredible store and the
people are so great there they're not
like jaded old like burnouts you know
like like Guitar Center yeah right like
hey do you got this eat a dick you know
like what you don't work out I mean like
I remember first going to Guitar Center
when I was young man and the guy would
just have a mustache and long hair and
i' like hey that's a Gibson V and he'd
be like yeah it is get out of here you
[__] idiot you like he worked there
oh yeah they were brutal oh they were
brutal but some guys were snobs in the
like there was a local music store when
I first went in and I remember uh I saw
Stuart Copeland for the first time so as
a youngster you think oh if I bought a
splash symbol then I could play like him
you know so I go in there and I didn't
know what it was called yeah and I was
like yeah I want to buy a symbol it's a
it's like a little come up and I'm
sitting there stammering and there's all
these [__] long-haired cool people
and the guy just looks at me goes you
mean a splash
a I was just like yeah and it to I was
so embarrassed that it didn't it took me
until getting it in my car I like wait
what [__] what the [__] did I take that
cuz I you just that whole thing being an
adult not knowing what not knowing
something was still really embarrassing
to me back then that's what The Comedy
Store hallway felt like to me the first
couple years like I'd be in there and
like you know there'd be a couple comics
and be like hey you guys going on and
they're like paid regulars and they'd be
like who the [__] are you you just look
at me with like lasers and just melt me
down I just Cruise away cuz I was so
excited like this The Comedy Store man
you guys going on you know that was
[__] brutal man now do you guys get
the same personalities as rock bands get
you know these let's say comedians that
think they're rock stars or act like
rock stars well we don't have we We Tour
individually so we don't have to deal
with the few times that I I've gone out
and done tours um back when I was early
on I did a couple of ones like a like
just for laughs would have one or uh you
know I did one that was on like a TV
show and then that was when I I I
started understand how difficult it is
to be in a band where it wasn't just
about me yeah and uh the car leaves when
I get there it's like everybody's got to
get there and then I really you know
then I started I did a couple of those
tours I started thinking okay there's
always the late guy there's the [__]
Hound or/ substance abuse guy there's
the [__] ego Maniac who's going to
burn the light yeah and and it just
starts being like uh and you have to
learn to
tolerate certain [__] and then know when
to call people out but not do it in a
way that embarrasses them so the whole
tour doesn't go to [__] and I was just
really going like like can you imagine
doing this in a [__] van year after
year after year after year and it gets
to the point I mean it gets to the point
a lot of those big bands they literally
have their own tour buses and they still
can't stand the sight of each other like
I don't even see his [__] bus it's
crazy right yeah Park his bus on the
other side I remember I saw
a band I won't say who they were but the
band uh buses were here and then the
lead singer bus was here and the lights
went down and he walked on here and the
band walked on this way and they played
and they left that way I was like wow
that happens very common yeah and then
you got to stay together because what am
I going to start over again it's like
the money you know and you got to
[__] dude that happens with a lot of
[__] it's like it's all it's like this
bad marriage and you're staying together
for the kids and the kids is the cash
yeah and I've seen that I've seen that
happen with writing teams radio shows
bands just so much [__] where people
just like we built this [__] thing
and now we're stuck I I mean it's easy
on the outside to look at it but I would
think it's some point to just be like
listen man I mean we're playing live at
some point we got to shoot each other a
look yeah if somebody's a little lost
like how does that will that guy not
help you out have you been in a band
situ I don't need to throw anybody under
the bus but have you been a band
situation where it's just like you're
not even talking and then you guys go
out there and put the smiles on and no
Smiles yes there has been situation but
there's no Smiles or snars you know
like what's that like cuz you're like
you're up there and you're going like H
this [__] guy you know yeah it sucks
you know it doesn't you guys don't have
separate buses you're not at that level
no it's it's not good for the creative
process and for the performance you know
but you know you get over it and you
move on and you know things usually iron
themselves out yeah and uh show what's
the most [__] up thing you've seen as
far as a situation like that you don't
got to name the band or anything just as
far as like you saw it and you're like
that band is going to break up within
like 24 hours and then maybe it happens
or maybe it doesn't what's the craziest
thing you saw um or something crazy well
I've seen similar things like what you
said where you know the bands are parked
you know uh members of the band are
parked in separate parts of the or
separate areas uh of the parking lot
backstage or you know they don't even
allow one of the musicians bus to enter
the backstage area let's say you know
you're playing The Sheds oh he could
park outside with the opening
axe wow so I've seen that and and of
course you know the artist complains and
you know hear all this stuff going on
Backstage you so it's um oh you're out
of camera oh sorry yeah wow that's crazy
you know but yeah it it happens you know
and I I've seen personalities and
witness you know certain personalities
ah that guy's troubled you shit's going
to go down give it a couple few years
and oh yeah watch that's what you end up
I can start doing that as a comedian
I've seen a few people I'm like oh that
person gets their own show somewhere
beginning season 2 mid season monster
comes out yeah Yep they're going to
[__] dress down a PA then they're
going to want a new director and then
the creators going to be allowed on set
like you just see that like not it's
definitely going to happen but you just
sit there going like all right you have
just enough of uh that like because what
it is you see somebody come in and
they're super nice hey hey hey hey and
then what it is is when you see them
just get just a little bit of status
just start getting spots and then
immediately you see them start then at
that point they've moved a little so
then now there's actually somebody
beneath them and then you see the way
that they treat them yes either stop
talking to them or just start being and
you just be oh that is that's a that's a
snowball Gathering snow and the higher
the more speed this thing gets it's just
going to be a uh it's going to be a [__]
show I've actually seen a couple um in
my lifetime in this business I've
watched a couple people literally become
like a like a Showbiz like like doing
clich cliche like [__] yeah where you're
just like Jesus dude we used to make fun
of that like you know when you talk
about when you make it you know the the
funny [__] I'm going to be the
I'm going to dump my wife and have a
[__] trophy wife and I'll be smoking
crack and you just joke about the flame
out and then you start watching people
doing that [__] just going like what the
what are you doing surround yourself
with people no nobody says no they're
all looking up to you like wow you're a
like just that type of [__] just going
like oh man that's brutal man it's
brutal I've seen it I seen it even back
in the day playing music on a small
level oh yeah like one band starts to
get a a a bigger draw than you and
before it was like a co-headlining and
then all of a sudden it's like well you
can't you know you guys can't use the
drum Riser tonight we're like what do
you mean like love all that music [__]
[__] friends we ate a burrito
together I know but it's just kind of
Biz you know I mean we got some anr guys
coming and you know we got we got we got
to look like you know look a certain way
and you're like dude we're setting up on
the floor and front of your drum Riser
now you're on the stage with like two
Ines now or your singer on the right or
left side of the drum kit all all looks
wrong it doesn't look rock at all you
know that kind of [__] you I heard a
story one time was one of those uh you
know older bands were getting together
yeah and the two lead singers still had
a rivalry so the headliner guy they had
this long [__] Runway that went all
the way out into the crowd he said the
opener guy couldn't use it and it was
this big dust up backstage like heard oh
yeah the yeah I'm I'm going to be the
guy that comes all the way out there but
you just you just stay back by the
drummer and you just looking it's almost
like two teams looking for a Competitive
Edge yeah and he was just like yeah you
can't use that and then the guy's like
what the [__] and the guy the other gu
just like well it's our Runway you're
using our [__] stage and just like
literally gets into that type of stuff
that's when you're just like come on man
yeah I heard uh Stones did that the
skinnard they said can't use the ego
ramp and they're like yeah all right
cool and they got out there and all
three the on Freebird [__] you all the
way out on the ego ramp just rocking
Freebird and was that the end of end of
their run on the tour it probably was
but the thing was they crushed so hard
that day it was when they opened for him
at like uh which can also get you
bounced yeah you want to get the job
done don't do it too well I remember I
opened for a comic early on and it was
the first time I featured for a guy I
didn't really know him and they had me
open for him and I went out and I wanted
to do great he recommended me and I came
off and I was like [__] that Crow's
great out there and he's like you leave
any laughs out there for me I was like
yeah yeah yeah yeah he goes no [__]
serious what what are you doing
hammering them I was like oh I had no
idea of that coming in I was like I just
wanted to do good for you so you didn't
Dean brought the fire he brought the
fire that night yeah there was this one
guy I remember I was in transition uh it
was back in '92 I had left Slayer and I
was starting a new band and I went to go
see this this band that was playing at
this venue and I meet up with the guys
you know before the show and the drummer
he he starts giving me this list of
everything they're doing oh yeah I was
just at Aussie's House aie made me
breakfast and we're going to be playing
this festival and that festival and this
festival and that must have been
horrible right and then he turns to me
after like playing with his hair what
are you doing you just like really so
what have you been up to it's like
really wow really bad attitude you know
yeah yeah just trying to he knew you
were out of Slayer trying to rub it on
you insane so he tried to hit me up a
couple years ago I never answered him oh
J did you go extra hard that show well I
wasn't uh I was in transition of forming
a new band at that time so that's why
nothing was going on it was a little
Hiatus and um you know so then he calls
me or sends me a message a couple years
back I never answered him I want nothing
to do with you D I remember you clearly
he's probably playing with his hair as
he was
sending like hey man if you know any
gigs out there let me know you should
have just hit him back matter of fact I
need a tech what are you doing this
summer oh man hey when you go out now
when you tour um how long uh like back
in the day you guys I mean you guys
would do like year twoe runs right well
I mean there's we would go on go on tour
for about a month you know so we would
do four shows day off three shows day
off you know um Jesus so and then off
for maybe a month and a half and then go
back out for another month so it's never
a year straight oh right never a year
straight um recently I did a tour uh I
did 19 shows in 19 days wow which band
with with film oh what a great band this
band man not anymore I'm not with that
band anymore oh did you leave yeah yeah
basic what happen I'm not going to talk
about it they didn't want me to promote
the band while I was with them and I'm
certainly not going to do it when I'm
without them wait they don't want you to
promote it while you're in the band what
kind of Sho yourself in the foot is I
don't want to talk about it
anymore wow yeah so I just said all
right I don't say you're in this band
that's the anti- making it plan yeah
that's it let's stick to Backyard
parties don't mention we got gigs or
nothing oh and and don't play hard oh my
want you to play a little softer wow so
you got a new band let's talk about it
cuz I know you got to get out of here
you're working on it right now today a
matter of fact yeah yeah I'm heading
over to Venice Beach Ross Rob Robinson
is producing it and um it it has a uh
Justin Pearson from retox and the Locust
Gabe Serbian from head wound City and uh
and the Locust and retox and he was in
cattle decapitation yeah and he's on
vocals cattle decapit
and they're all vegans wow oh my God
like vegan
metal it's awesome and they uh uh oh my
God and Michael crane from uh from reto
uh these guys they're they're uh do it
yourself underground you know punk
rockers you know right and um it's
brutal it's the band's called Dead cross
and it's heavy thrash in your face
without any you know computer editing
and all this fancy stuff it's it's raw
you guys are just recording it right
there at Venice Beach at Ross's house
yes he's got an incredible setup there
yeah he does man he's just got this like
four story super Loft right by the
Muscle Beach Park oh is this the guy I
rode with yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah cool his Pat is incredible and they
get some magic out of there down in the
guest house he turned it into a
full-blown studio and it's just fire in
there man that's where I first met you
yeah he was he's a great motivator he
really he knows how to talk to you and
and get the most out of you out of your
performance and and really you know
fires you up yeah he's pretty he's like
I learned positive from him yeah and
Burr too I learned that like Burr used
to I'd be like H [__] that you go
actually I don't know you got to look at
this and that you're wrong there and I'm
like no you got to train your if you're
going to get I think just in general if
you're going to succeed you have if your
if your brain is not where it needs to
be you're not going to get get off the
ground cuz you're constantly going to
just be like no people going to be like
no no sorry can't do it and you have to
be able to not let that just be like
this albatross around your neck and just
take it into this [__] depression I I
mean you know what year did that change
for you though because you were there
for a long time you were you were angry
right uh oh yeah yeah I was but I was I
always had this weird sort of overall
positive outlook which is why when big
[__] happens I don't flip I flip out
over a little stuff like when they made
these [__] the tops of these water
bottles smaller the Caps I didn't
understand why and I couldn't became
frustrating to open I would LIF what the
[__] are they doing these cheap [__]
and I found out it was like this
environmental thing then I'm like but
you still got the whole other bottle the
whole thing's [__] like that [__]
gets me going for whatever and drives my
wife nuts but like I there was somewhere
in like my 30s when uh you know when
just the Fallout of my anger just had
reached this thing and I was just kind
of like going like all right I'm hitting
35 most people live to be about 70 I'm
kind of halfway through this on a good
run am I really going to be the angry
guy am I going to be angry the whole you
know and a lot of that you know and I
started coming out here more and East
Coast people oh you going to lose your
Edge you're going to lose your Edge and
it's like dude I got plenty of that I
got plenty of that I need I need to
stick the toes in the sand here be
compressed so um yeah it just became
that and then I I fortunately was not a
clinically depressed person I just was
susceptible the negative thought because
there was a lot of that around me when I
was growing up so I was able to get
myself out of it so now I just sort of
have like I just I can kind of catch it
when it's happening where I just go like
okay all right you want to just think
that for the rest of the [__] day or
you want to go to the gym go down and
try something new cook something like
something that's going to get me in a
good mood as opposed to but I definitely
had those years of of laying on the
futon not writing jokes for [__] a
month and just being like Oh what am I
doing this sucks why that person get a
break and I didn't I you know I went
through that [__] but I mean fortunately
that that was something that was only
like it was a short period in I remember
you told me something that but people
still think I'm angry because they watch
my ACT but I remember you told me
something you said look man you're going
to probably make it and get somewhere
and uh you're gonna have a [__] uh
you're really gonna want to tell all
those people that said no to you to [__]
off he's like don't do that just go with
it you know they said No at that time
hopefully you won't care but there's the
thing this business is hard enough as it
is you don't need to be walking around
be going let me tell you something
[__] [__] back in 199 cuz
they don't even remember yeah you Clos
the door on me and for all you know they
had some crisis going on in their home
life that caused them to be short oh or
how about you weren't good enough yeah
at that point you were starting out so
it's like you know I always tell guys
that like cuz there was a guy that
[__] me out of money early on in my
career and then he made some comment
about my act and really you know and I
was brand new so I was like you know
just totally wide open I had no you know
deflector Shield so I went right to the
soul and I just remember I used to I
used to lay in bed at night thinking
about it I'm going to do this I'm going
to do that and he's going to walk up to
say hello and I'm going to be like
listen [__] [__] [__] all
this thing it was like the f word f word
f word and I remembered I ended up
getting
something I got a a small acting part or
whatever and and I was at the Laugh
Factory yeah and I ended up running into
the guy I haden't seen him in years I
walked by he goes hey man I heard about
that he's like congratulations
congratulations and I wasn't even
thinking and I was I just oh hey yeah
thanks a lot blah blah and then he
walked out I remember after you walked
out looking like oh that was the moment
that was the moment I S I was sat there
I was like you know what I didn't give a
[__] I don't care guy has no effect on
my [__] life he had an effect on my
life you know he made one comment and I
allowed that to to to snowball so like
even now when people do [__] to me that
like really uh like pisses me off or
whatever like I I try to manage it down
to like ah bill you know who gives a
[__] yeah who gives a [__] yeah you're
selling tickets you're getting away with
murder yeah you're a working comedian I
mean I'm stealing money so I there only
so upset I can get about [__] like that
yeah yeah well congrats on FIS for
family man than check that out so
[__] funny man my daughter was the
one she was here Dad watch this I said
Bill I know him really wow this is great
oh your daughter watches it that's so
great how old is she she's 15 wow wow
she gets it I got um I did that uh
co-created with Mike price from The
Simpsons and uh he was a guy that when
we met him like we were just talking
about childhood stories and he just had
the funniest stuff and like a lot of
writer a really introverted he had this
big personality and boom and laugh was
just and like he is a a creative for
course so now that the show's doing well
people keep going he you created this
show I I did it with Mike price from The
Simpsons and like you know I had like a
c to the idea and then like he helped me
flesh it out and that's awesome yeah and
we got a killer writers room and all of
that and it was basically when we were
interviewing the writers you know if you
had like a happy childhood and you you
know parents who listened we were like
all right see you later somebody came up
and was just like yeah we take out the
family car and my brother threw me down
the stairs for no reason like all man
send us script let's see let's see what
you got so um for people your listeners
who haven't uh heard about it's on
Netflix there's six episodes because
when we came at him I don't think they
you know they were thinking oh comedian
he's going to do this type of show and I
told him I wanted to do a cartoon yeah I
think they were kind of like that's kind
of
weird but fortunately I got in business
with uh Wild West which is Vince Von's
people and he came he literally Vince
came to the pitch meetings yeah so as
much as they were looking at why is this
dick joke comic one of do a cartoon they
keep looking over that's an aist movie
star all right we'll give you six we see
what you can do cuz a lot of people were
asking how come there wasn't 12 that's
why because I think that they wanted to
see if we could execute it and uh from
what I'm hearing it's doing well Netflix
does not have ratings but we've been
getting great feedback from them so you
know God willing um you know I'll get
the second season and if I don't I won't
go you what [__] that [__] I'm not
going to do i' be like hey you know they
were nice enough to give me six I get it
I get it so it's brilliant it's
hilarious I love it I'm waiting for
season two cuz I want to come in with
that yeah man hey Murphy I got to get my
voice in there man I I keep seeing Vic
I'm like that's me the neighbor Vic I
love that oh yeah I love him he's just
like hey Murphy look at this [__] I got
right here in this big screen you ain't
got [__] no no no he roots for you he
roots for you that's the thing we had to
make it like he does like he's just yeah
when he finds out Frank has a bigger TV
he's like all right man it's great so
Frank's really fighting this one-sided
War yeah um Sam Rockwell does the uh the
the voice for that Lord he's great on
that Laura dur does Sue Murphy the wife
and Justin long does Kevin uh he's been
crushing it Haley Reinhardt does me just
there just Dave Kenner Gary Cole there's
just been a zillion people Mo Collins
yeah does so many voices on it it's it's
awesome and I really hope we get to come
back and do some more but if we only got
to do six I know we swung for the fences
people're [__] great I'm telling you
man it's the talk still right now comedy
St guy last night was talking to me
about it I go yeah dude I watched them
the first [__] day you know hey are
you watching yeah I watch I was like
last night I went down to the comicy
store and like a couple Comics came up
to me say hey man FIS for family is is
really funny so you make a comedian
laugh I don't give a [__] what level
they're on that's that's that's awesome
man and uh your temper on that show is
amazing I had K on [__] I mean one of
the first one you're trying to hang up
the phone
[__] you're like yeah I I grew up I grew
up around a lot of like uh big-hearted
people that would give you the shirt off
their back and they had massive rage
issues and I think asides from being
dysfunctional I think when you're the
kind of guy that will give your shirt
off your back yeah when you don't get
that in return that it's like I think a
lot of rage people have an issue with
the lack of common courtesy with like uh
their fellow man like I know I I in
traffic lose my [__] [__] when
somebody you know just makes a [__]
move that blocks you and you have to
wait until they're done with their move
and they easily could have just if they
just gave a [__] yeah that you were
behind there they'd pull up a little bit
and they don't I'm always you know dude
when I'm the first guy to make a left at
the red light dude like like my
responsibility I feel is not that the
guy behind me the guy behind me the two
guys back I want I want three cars that
should be your [__] goal and traffic
would move a lot better out here if
people did that but they don't so um I
grew up around a lot of rage people and
uh I definitely I have it uh I get
[__] furious on people that are late
it just makes me crazy because I'm
always on time I like to be professional
and and you think I don't want to
[__] sleep an extra hour I do but now
I got up early but you slept that extra
hour and now we're late to the [__]
gig and you know it makes me [__]
steaming absolutely cuz I just want to
be Pro you know no I just don't want to
stand around waiting for some [__]
guy no well that's it I'm like really
man and then and then and this is the
worst when they text traffic at what
[__] time is there not traffic every
[__] day you can't use that as two
minutes away that means half hour away
I'm out front two minutes away let's get
out of here man thanks guys for doing
the podcast wor aome and uh we're going
to put together this Birthday Bash and
you guys are going to play we're going
to do some
ACDC be I'm dying to see you getting up
you're going to front the band right I
front the band dude love I front it
strong I come out it's just Bond Full
Tilt that's awesome and then you know
the last song is night Prowler and uh
that song to me it was funny I was with
Marin and we were going to see the
stones and we drove to San Diego and he
put on the Highwood hell record and I
realized it's just a masterpiece you
know and it gets that night Prowler at
the end and then he's like sh but n and
you're like that [__] guy rules yeah
it really dates the album too you're
like all right that's 1979 tells you're
right there morg for morg the fact that
that was still okay to do that yeah
right my OCD I had to [__] untwist
the cord
there looks good thanks guys man thanks
everybody foring in thank you so
much
yes yes yes yes